PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to "Deconstructing Chatbots."
I am Priyanka Vergadia.
And in this episode,
we are going
to explore how to
integrate Dialogflow
with Google Assistant.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Once you build your
agent on Dialogflow,
you can use the
one-click integration
to connect to various
platforms, such as Google
Assistant, Slack, Facebook
Messenger, Twitter, and more.
Today, we are going to look
at integrating Dialogflow
with Actions on Google.
Actions on Google
is a platform where
you can create software to
extend the functionality
of Google Assistant.
By integrating Dialogflow
with Actions on Google,
you can reach over
500 million devices
that support Google Assistant,
such as smart speakers, phones,
cars, TVs, or watches.
Let's consider the same
appointment scheduler chatbot
that we built in the
previous episode and work
through the integration.
Click on Integrations.
We are going to explore Google
Assistant integration today.
So let's just click that.
In the pop-up window, we
define Explicit Invocation.
What intent do we
want to trigger
when a user says, OK, Google,
talk to Smart Scheduler?
Smart Scheduler here
is our trigger name.
We will see where to set
it up in just a little bit.
In our case, Welcome
Intent is the perfect spot
for the user to land on.
So we will just stick to that.
Let's say a user
says, OK, Google,
ask Smart Scheduler to set
an appointment for 5:00
PM tomorrow.
That is an implicit invocation.
So in this case, we could invoke
our Schedule Appointment intent
directly, since we know exactly
what the user wants to do.
If we want the
service to be only
available for signed-in
users, then you
can check the Sign-In
Required button.
In our case, it's just
a demo, so we will just
keep it open to everybody.
We are then going to
click on Test First.
Since we just developed our
app, let's see how it functions,
or if it functions correctly.
OK, that looks great.
Now let's explore the
Manage Assistant App button.
This provides us to set up the
invocation name to our chatbot.
We called it Smart Scheduler.
This is also the place to
select male or female voice
for your assistant.
Going back to Overview, we have
already built our application.
And it's ready to test.
When you are ready
for deployment,
make sure you have selected the
countries you want to deploy in
and the surfaces you want
your actions to run on.
You will have to
provide a description
for your application,
Sample Invocations.
For example, here we've added
Talk to Smart Scheduler.
You can add more.
It also requires two images--
one small and one large.
Contact details and
privacy information
fill up all those things.
Once you have done
all that and feel
comfortable to push the
application to production,
use the Release option
to submit to production.
Of course, here, we have not
finished the overviewed items.
So we don't have the ability
to submit to production yet.
You can also enable
the launch in beta
to open it up for
up to 200 users.
With alpha release, you
can enable your action
for up to 20 users without
submitting for review.
All right.
So today, we used our
Appointment Scheduler chatbot
that we built in
the previous episode
and integrated it with
Actions on Google.
Don't miss the next episode
of deconstructing chatbots,
because we are going
to make our appointment
scheduler a little bit smarter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]